24th birthday yesterday for julio
and now makes his fourth start of the
season he's 1-0 with a 240. here he
comes
and gets tati's swinging three big
swings and misses on fastballs one gone
and here's machado
machado back spins a fly ball to deep
left center field peterson and pollock
back aj pollock able to bring it in
heck of a play by the former gold glover
in center field in arizona for out
number two here in the first nobody on
tommy pham coming up
this is in the air to left field and
this is deep back goes peterson that
ball is gone
home run for tommy pham his second in a
padres uniform and the padres jump on
top one to nothing now eric hosmer sends
it out to deep right center field that
is back and that is gone padres go back
to back in the first first tommy pham
now eric hosmer and the padres take a
two-nothing lead in la tonight on the
mound is chris paddock 24 year old
making his fifth start he's got the
fourth team to change up the curveball
and he's got a two-run lead and up comes
corey seeger for his first at-bat since
last friday he's got his hitting the
ball as well as anybody in baseball
seeger turns on one fly ball right
center field back to the wall and boy he
didn't miss a beat did he
first step back back ties the game with
a two-run home run rory seeger not
missing a beat not missing this fastball
inner half and you know he swings at
strikes one of the most aggressive
hitters in baseball
jay pollock coming up pollock was a
terrific catch in the top half of the
first inning
two and one and pollock with a fly ball
to left field and he has hit it out and
the dodgers just like that take a three
to two lead
two home runs for the padres in the top
of the first two for the dodgers in the
bottom of the first for pollock his
fifth home run of the year his tenth rbi
dodgers three and the padres two now
betts who was hit by a pitch in his
first played appearance and then he
would come around to score on corey
seeger's
home run paddock throws and bats goes
after the first pitch drives him out of
right center field it's over olivares
over the wall and gone
opposite field two run shot mookie bets
third home run for the dodgers in the
first two innings and they lead 5-2
here's pollock who homered his first at
bat his fifth of the year
shoots one towards the right field
corner myers won't get there and
pollock's got extra bases again
rbi double for aj pollock to go along to
the home run and the dodgers lead 6-2
here's barnes
one ball one strike
and there's a fly ball to left field
that's well hit and austin barnes has
just hit it out for the dodgers their
fourth home run of the night
and we're still not finished with the
fourth inning we got some thunder
tonight
that ball's lifted to left center field
back towards the wall betts has done it
again
they're out of their collective minds
tonight
that is five home runs over the first
three plus innings for the dodgers two
for mookie betts
he's gonna have a few chances tonight
oral at a major league record he has
five career three home run games
that's third most in major league
history
lifts a fly ball to left center field
back towards the wall it is gone
monkey with another three home run game
in the history of baseball three men
have done this six times
johnny mize sammy sosa and now mookie
betts
well they've been 16 players in major
league baseball to hit four home runs in
major league baseball history bets grabs
it gently along third charging garcia's
got it no throw he goes a second
everybody's safe
it's not a home run but that's a settle
for a four hit game
[Applause]
mcgee finally gets him
his 11th strikeout of the year
he'll try one two again profile
tomahawks it to right bets is back to
make the catch
one of them seven and 12 the other seven
and 13. no surprise for the mariners but
the angels people figured would be a
postseason contender
that does it a swing and a miss to
finish this thing off
a night where milky bent steals the show
hitting three home runs gets plenty of
support three other home runs six total
in an 11-2 win
dodger offense last night got started
late here they started in the first and
they kept scoring all the way to the
fifth then they shut it down and called
off the jam but another nice win